[Music]
get this view this villas got left you
can see some of these for instructions
from Salaam
that one's me up
[Music]
this is a story about Saudi people not
Saudi politics today I'm gonna bring you
up into the mountains of Saudi Arabia
[Music]
this country is all about speed traps in
speed bumps there's the camera icon of
the camera and there's the speed limit
above so unless you know Arabic good
luck with that one
Salaam
Salaam Salaam okay
kids guys these kids have a nice way to
landcruiser okay so here's the here's
the cost 42 reals
28 litres I'll have to do the math and a
text here but that's very cheap genesee
genesee can sometimes press a line where
it becomes abnormal and often first
or to control others if you are worried
about your own tendency
toward jealousy you
you need to take the hard no got
yourself this it's where we're going up
to the top there
[Music]
very rugged up here and some of the
mountain is falling into the road
this is one of the steeper roads I've
been on in the world and I've been in
Nepal it is this car this little Chevy
spark I had to put it in the love
okay online there's pretty much nothing
in English on this region very little
so we're gonna discover this together I
don't know exactly what we're gonna get
into you almost didn't get up the last
section look at this landscape though
wild so surreal
Peter it's common in these parts you
pick up hitchhikers
yeah alright this is really a lot for a
lot jeez in the other hobby aha so I'm
gonna I'm gonna make the claim steepest
road in the world is in Saudi Arabia
little halts in the road trip just just
just went on to this guy so looks like
we'll be hanging here for a bit
tire repair in these parts
oh I got a spare I got a spare what am I
thinking should have a spare
and your friend here had plenty of
chances for another ride but he's
staying faithful
we're good man
I guess I did have a hobbies mm-hmm
[Music]
you could on a job you're a classy guy
man
cheer come on this is absolutely
stunning you guys this is mind-blowing
I'm gonna show you the most amazing
shots here like it's 360 degrees of
craziness I can't get it in the camera
frame
this guy might be the worst driver in
Saudi if we look at his car he's hit at
least at least a good 15 people Salam
check out this guy's driving skills I
mean he's hit at least I'm gonna I'm
gonna put thirty people with his car
maybe forty in India it's chaos it's
crazy but it's the chaos somehow works
here there they're the most amount of
speed traps the most amount of speed
bumps and big speed bumps it doesn't do
anything it's still absolute chaos and
on the roads not complaining just
observing but let's observe this which
is much more interesting absolutely
stunning up here
cool temperatures green you can see some
of these forged structures intermingled
between the newer homes so there are
million of these roads just twisting but
they're just twisting up and down these
mountain sides
it's very tribal feeling up here as you
might imagine it seems like everyone
knows everybody
the elements of a great road trip are
get up some distance you got to have a
lot of unknown and then you got to have
like something go wrong
whether that be flat tire
you also need that interaction you need
that cool interaction with people which
I had a camera down a bunch of dead ends
a lot of different looks up here not
scared looks but like who's this outside
guy what's he doing up here
which makes sense what am i doing up
here okay I'm trying to show you guys
I'm trying to show you guys the
contrasts of this country it's not just
sand and I got to get into it if I'm
gonna do that so here we are
Wow
Yemen is only think over this next
mountain range here I think roughly 40 K
or something
so in these border regions you always
have that bleed over right that's that's
what I'm talking about
and these border regions you always have
that bleed over of culture and
ethnicities so maybe it feels a little
bit more
like Yemen up here see if the spark can
get up this road
I don't I don't did this they
can do it honestly
so long try okay
[Music]
Wow
Salam Salam Wow beautiful house Abdullah
yeah beautiful you make this place from
USA California San Francisco thank you
do you think it here hi yeah I stay here
as you like okay thank you brother look
at this view this fellas got one of the
coolest views
Wow Abdullah is doing well beautiful man
this is amazing it's like a mansion
this is cribs I try playing amazing this
isn't massive looks like
or it widths of our 10 rooms something
like that
shoot DOMA ok yeah let's go up
Wow a lot of building up here
or people to list with the other kids
they like living is the fight for civil
boom
no cookie huh yeah so just Abdullah his
wife oh yeah she's three and three
children
yeah yeah yeah once
interesting it's like a beam but bitter
[Applause]
good good good yeah sit here extreme
sitting though okay
what is that
it smells different than honey I said
lesson
it's like honey with a smoky flavor to
kit on shook it on hey brick brick yes
we got this high in the mountains
everything is is green because of this
fog with all the moisture comes from the
fog just like in California on the coast
doesn't rain in the summers but then the
red would stay alive through the fog
same thing is happening up here
it's like a bread Minturn
just stop - this total restaurant and
this is how they do inside your stomach
then just get a big
I Drive up his driveway his super steep
driveway yeah the car with with the
GoPro with the camera right around his
kids total stranger obviously I'm not
from around here he he says hello out of
the top window and comes down to
introduce himself bring me in for tea
show me his house share some time I mean
just imagine that imagine that imagine
that reality okay I'm just gonna be
totally fair here imagine in the West
imagine in Western Europe or the States
Canada Australia say a more developed
country Saudi is developed but out here
it's it's a little more less developed
and say some Saudi guy or Middle Eastern
guy going up someone's driveway getting
out of the car with a camera and you
know that Western person saying hey come
on in let me show you the house let's
hang out even though we can't speak a
word together let me pour you some tea
and it's not to say that people on the
west aren't friendly it's not like that
at all no I'm not I'm not on
the West it's just it's a testament to
this part of the world it's something
very unique and special about this part
of the world okay it happens in other
parts of the world but the Middle East
in general it's super hospitable this is
very very kind
it's I hope I caught on camera it's
always a hard one to get when you're you
know you know on someone's space you
know trying to connect with them you
don't have language it's a little off
with that and then you're you know
you're you're videoing someone it's it's
not the easiest to do but it's it's the
story I want to show it's like that's
all I'm doing this for us to show the
human story not the political story not
hedonistic pleasures just like what like
give these people from here a face and a
voice to the world they don't have one
it's just the reality like I'll get all
sorts of for these videos I'm sure
just because I'm in Saudi Arabia but
it's it's unfair not to give these
people a voice you saw a beautiful they
were you can't stage that ship that
cannot be orchestrated can't be paid for
just genuine hospitality so tomorrow I'm
off to I'm off to a Wadi which is like
an oasis of sorts I believe you can't
see out the window now but this this
hotel is a bat I don't know how many
feet what we're up high and it got foggy
tonight and the fog came in and it got
chilly out and everything's green
because of the fog so thanks for coming
along on that journey that was a very
interesting day and tomorrow I feel will
be the same okay thanks so much good
night
you